qui ne pétrit bon pain ne mange il
s'agit bien là d'une expérience à
laquelle on participait les enfants de
l'atelier pâte à pain de la ferme de
Gally à Saint-Cyr-l'École pendant 45
minutes il découvre les ingrédients
nécessaires à la fabrication du pain
puis mettre en pratique la recette nos
petits apprentis boulangers ont du pain
sur la planche au programme moudre le
blé petrir et façonner la pâte le but du
jeu c'est vraiment de chaque enfant est
compris les ingrédients de la pâte à
pain et d'avoir à la fin chacun sa pâte
et puis ça sera à faire cuire à la
maison après parce qu'il faut deux
heures du coup pour que la pâte lève
bien les explications de l'animatrice
sont claires et à la portée des enfants
la recette semble déjà être bien
maîtrisée la levure du sel
la farine
cet atelier pratique laisse ici au plus
jeune le temps et la liberté d'action
nécessaire à l'apprentissage de la
cuisine qui n'est pas toujours chose
évidente à la maison je trouve que c'est
assez ludique en plus ils peuvent voir
les animaux avant de faire l'atelier ils
ont appris des choses en faisant
l'atelier des choses qui font pas
forcément à l'école et qui font pas
forcément avec nous ce qu'on a pas le
temps donc du coup je trouve ça assez
sympa pas cher et pas loin trois
ateliers pâte à pain sont proposés
chaque jour pendant les vacances
scolaires sans oublier les classiques de
la ferme ouverte et les activités
thématiques